hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment today we're
talking about the controversial
adaptation of The Killing Joke today on
the pen all we have three lovely people
we're gonna go with Ayanna first ina way
what's up that's me
how's it going you excited to at least
talk about this
I am excited to talk about it okay all
right I was very excited to see it we
all know I think we all were not it for
a while how excited we were
and I know me was excited me was excited
excited for all of the background and
we'll get into that moment mm-hmm had
the roofs what's going on I have
feelings about yeah I saw your Twitter
post about it there's a lot to discuss
in one second and of course my pal your
pal mr. Brian Porter what's up what did
you overall think of it give me a little
thing he loved it and we're gonna
discuss now okay everybody so the first
thing we're gonna change this up a
little bit from how we usually do this
we're going to talk about specific
subjects here so Ayanna you're gonna
lead this versus the discussion and it
is about the 30 minute prologue prologue
is not 30 minutes it's not supposed to
be three minutes
yes this is the killing joke but as
people who have read the comic no that's
not really long enough to make into a
seventy five minutes yeah it films so
they had to add filler and that's
exactly what it felt like I did I was
extremely extremely extremely
disappointed in the Batgirl story in
general
I personally don't ship Bruce and Barb
no I don't but everyone I think the only
person who does yeah Tim does I mean I
got you I got my ships like that too
they ain't gonna happen but like if I
had control over it they would happen I
feeling it I got you
I understand that but it didn't feel
like there was any sort of explanation
or any
sort of tension at all other than
Barbara's whining and pining after her
hot for teacher feelings and it was
unbearable for me it just didn't seem
grounded it felt Hollow there was there
there was there was no tension at all I
did not like it there was no buildup
except that fight and that guy don't
think was even a good sexy fight like
you know if you're gonna fight and then
bang like at least like exactly that was
yeah yeah yeah yeah the gay best friends
so awful he was hilarious so bad that
everyone was everyone in the theater
when I saw it was dying at the line like
girl I thought I wanted so much to like
I wanted so much to like the bad girl
story all it did like I said all it did
was establish that like Babs has messes
everything up it was like just her
constantly being like oh I messed that
up
oh yeah I mean I guess my issue with
that whole prologue is I mean I know we
it is a bra before the actual movie get
started but a prologue is like 10
minutes max this was almost half the
movie was right was this Batgirl story
which is completely separate like I'm
alright that's my problem
he's like a prologue is complete as long
as it ties in but like okay so we're
building it up and like now Bruce has a
reason to be so upset at the Joker for
doing this to Barbara like okay I'm
feeling you it's now your girl there's
even more attention and
they break it off and they like are like
and we're done that was the last time I
was bad girl here's the Killing Joke
guys morkul at the end yeah yeah weird
um yeah just that whole thing how is
handled this was not I don't know what
they were thinking man we know what I
did like in the prologue that I felt
like was getting somewhere and then like
didn't really get anywhere was was a
France Paris what a terrible name right
but there was the whole scene where he
like bangs a hooker with like the
pillowcase as the Batgirl Cowell whoa
speech are super awesome that was
probably my favorite part of the
prologue no it was like so dark and I
was like oh this is oh this is going
somewhere what uh what are really really
creepy yeah adding some really sweet
like you know put that in a separate
Batgirl movie though you know what I
mean I don't know it didn't go away
didn't hear a joke and then she kicked
his butt and I was she saw me abyss I
was getting really worried that they
were gonna set it up completely
different and that he was gonna end up
being the Joker
that's what I was thinking I was like
this is not your animals voice but he's
got like this chin thing and I'm like
this is where I was I was excited when
they first announced like this prologue
backers like that's really cool cuz
Batgirl is a great character and Barbara
Gordon so like setting that up
beforehand what happens to her in this
which is kind of a defining moment I
mean like that's cool to get a little
bit of buildup yeah I was expecting like
10 minutes that would tie into the rest
of the story though and this was a full
half an hour that didn't have anything
to do with the main story in this and
that's like we said doesn't make any
sense why you would do that I don't
understand I get that Bruce Timm really
likes that like we're talking about
Batgirl and and Batman going back to
Bennet and Beyond hinting at them having
relationship and stuff but it just
doesn't flow with this whatsoever and
with all the minds behind this like
trying so hard to make this
great I don't understand how that could
have slipped through the cracks yeah
see my thing with it was I you know
going in I knew that they had the
prologue you know make it the feature
length that was cool with that I knew
was the boughs like okay cool buff it up
here a little bit if it works if it's
good I'm right on board if it doesn't I
don't give a because there's only
gonna be one time that I have to watch
that and that's it in the theaters and
when I get this on DVD no you just give
I will skip it yeah and I will only
watch The Killing Joke so I don't give a
like I did not care okay it wasn't
as good as I hoped it had been whatever
we're on to the Killing Joke and I
forget about the prologue it doesn't
matter to me inconsequential like it it
isn't consequential and that's why you
was to see The Killing Joke and I saw
the killer it's a part of the movie I
mean I was so mad about the prologue
that even when they started killing Joe
I didn't even care I was like oh here
here's the real story but I don't even
care because I'm so probably ready to
watch it that much now honestly because
that's kind of I don't get how it was
taints it because it's like you don't
pick and choose what isn't and isn't in
the movie but it wasn't in the book so I
don't care my so I don't care right when
I heard that The Killing Joke was gonna
be her as a movie it's like okay Killing
Joke is moving they're adding something
in the beginning I get it I don't give a
I only focus on the cop but you're
always talking about how like comic
adaptations like when they deviate you
get offended
lieutenant area story they didn't edit
throughout the actual Killing Joke there
the toad splitted into The Killing Joke
would you be officially rage absolutely
I believe what The Killing Joke was a
perfect adaptation okay in the beginning
then because you don't care about the
story
did you like nope nope it was my weird
it was off it felt weird like I switched
kept like elongating and then shorting
and then mom getting in like it was so I
didn't notice it's just it felt like the
quality of animation in the beginning
was less than when you actually got to
The Killing Joke obviously because we
going to get in there like it was so it
seems like they didn't care about it at
all because even the animation wasn't up
to like and I understand it wasn't
supposed to be a theatrical release
until we all demanded it yeah good job
Internet okay but even the other DC
animated films have a higher standard of
animation than this like I expected more
some some of them are the same quality
throughout right it might be more
consistent with their style but right
okay you don't like I know you don't
like anime style it's just the style of
it is not right right yes okay no see I
heard about that going into it at the
animation style is great yeah I heard
that like it was kind of like Skippy and
weird yeah right but when I silent I
didn't really notice it all that much I
mean like it didn't bug me I thought
it's fine whatever
I mean I mean I was there for like the I
just wanted to see this on the screen so
I wasn't really paying attention to that
as much but I didn't know it's like here
and there I didn't like how Batman's
ears came out a little bit like horns I
thought that character Maya
like even in The Killing Joke like which
he's you know he is what it is in the
the comic and they've translated him
fine but like with the whole prologue
and everything he just ended up being so
heartless what do you weigh the bad girl
stuff that yeah it was so weird hearing
Kevin Conroy and I have that picture of
him in my mind then swear to me swear to
me it was weird hearing Kevin Conroy
then intermingling with the Batgirl
drama and then them going at it it's
like I feel uncomfortable
because that's not the Batman like it's
it was just weird because what I
associate to that voice all the other
Batman is like I wouldn't do that I can
tell you from experience well I feel
like that was almost an acting choice
that was yeah because like Mark Hamill
found a way to just make this Joker's
voice just a little bit different
because he knew that it was a different
Joker than he played on the series
whereas I feel like Kevin Conroy didn't
necessarily do that he was just like
okay this is my Batman voice but with
Barbara no yeah oh no you're right on
that I mean but overall I thought it was
so awkward too because it like go this
weird cut and he like grabs her but and
then like we just got to do this it was
like I wish they would have hand up with
her shirt so we didn't actually see her
in the bra it was just like you see you
see the like and that fee now that comes
off Batgirl in a bra straddling Batman
yes you're right I mean weird it makes
sense in the story whatever like I don't
care about I know but it was just super
weird and kind of uncomfortable like not
I love how Bruce Timm quotes okay I love
Bruce Timm look at me he's responsible
like almost directly for a Batman series
he co-created that with Eric Radomski
and everything but I mean he's a really
driving force behind his animated movies
and the original Iron Man universe and
stuff and when he's talking about this
relationship
he says that well you know even going
back as far as the atom was so Adam
West's show you can see like little
tension I'm like if you take the Adam
West Show and any point seriously there
is something wrong is he going senile is
Bruce going little off the rails I love
you Bruce what are you doing man
no no that's his ship I don't care I
don't respect that ship I'll sink that
ship
we got a move on e we're running at time
folks I wanted to talk about it real
quick you want to talk about the musical
number we'll go in general the
adaptation of The Killing Joke look into
this and that was part of it was the one
thing I think I was most looking forward
to I think everything else I had a very
clear picture in my head shooting a
barber the whole like everything else
was like the the freakshow circusy
sideshow thing like I kind of everything
was spot-on everything was exactly how I
pictured and then I was like okay
musical number blow me away and it did
it was spot-on here's great so good they
made a great choice with the music
because it could have been easy for them
to take it like super creepy card just
perfect that's exactly what the Joker
would have done like just put a Broadway
number on to Barbara Gordon's Limp
bleeding body yeah it made sense for
sure yeah it had a great effect worked
with that effect I thought it was
fantastic and it was just it was so
interesting to hear mark hamill Joker
the Joker singing a Broadway show tunes
it was weird creepy good without trying
so hard to be creepy right I totally fit
with the story which is incredibly
strange because of how dark the story is
then yeah I wanted to talk about the
music in general so we talked about this
musical number but the music okay they
did like a little documentary after the
movie like in theatres about it the I
think this is a larger problem in
general doesn't happen in all movies but
the theme is getting lost in movie music
now like the the reason why themes are
so strong and powerful is because you
can distort them in different moments to
enhance a scene and enhance emotion and
stuff and in this they're talking about
how much oh it's music to madness and
everything I'm like it
it's it's good quality music I could
tell but like you didn't give anybody a
discernible theme or like all the themes
in here but you can't it's too subtle we
can't hear anything give I'm not saying
full-on go give the the Joker the
animated series thing that did it in did
it today you don't have to do that but
you can give him something specific to
the movie this is a 90-minute movie or
write something something I think that's
the loss of Shirley Walker with these
animated projects that she's not around
anymore and she really got it I think
the guys they get to do these these
tracks usually just don't
nothing really connects anymore we need
some themes back you can make new themes
but put a theme in there that we all
recognize and then like I'm talking
about in different scenes you distort it
enhance a scene that was not present in
this and I was a little disappointed in
the music and I was a little ya
disappointed in the in the ending
talking about how much effort was put
into it and I was like I can tell that
you know the skill is there but there's
there's no emotional connection to music
that could have made this so much better
easily and it didn't but that's just my
rant on the music in general the
adaptation Killing Joke this is my
favorite book like pretty much comic
book period I love The Killing Joke
since I read it like 10 years ago or
something so I had high hopes like
everyone else did going into this but
the actual adaptation from book to
screen like is it's good but I there's
there's scenes that definitely hit the
bull's eye absolutely but then it just
seems like it's missing something I
thought maybe that's the music maybe it
just wasn't that was the missing missing
thing in there that didn't you know
elevate it I don't know what it was but
it felt like something was missing I
don't know what it was I can't quite put
my finger on it it still is still a good
after adaptation I could still see they
tried really hard to really accurately
do this but I don't know what it was
maybe it was the music but if that I
don't know I don't have to be watched a
couple more times before I decide that
the ending no is perfect anything
outside that was made I was always
wondering I thought and I like that they
kind of addressed the fan canon of like
you know Batman
Oh Joker because like he laughed longer
than the Joker oh my gosh is this it
yeah hinting that this really happens
right yes
Conroy laughing is great it was that
almost terrifying yes so weird to hear
caiman laugh because we never hear that
and yeah this animated series you know
Justice League and yeah we don't hear
him laugh and then he's laughing almost
maniacally and it's like whoa that's
kind of creepy
yes Batman laughing is not yeah like it
was it was awesome to see but it's like
wow that's right grapes quickly any
other adaptation points from from book
to screen that you guys I loved
Commissioner Gordon was a really really
a great character in in this adaptation
of it he was a lot more relatable like
Batman was like almost more unhinged
kind of a dick like you guys like this
really like brutal Batman in this I
would say like very like hard and
Commissioner Gordon was so relatable and
just he felt so bad from and Joker's
like yep drove him then he's like yeah
go uh go breeding prison I'm fine yeah I
did think that they could yeah it was a
little just I think that there was
definitely some time in between Batman
going there you know he kind of is kind
of out of it for a couple minutes a
couple seconds at least and then he kind
of snapped like no no you gotta bring
him in by the book this in the movie it
was like he just goes over to him alone
oh my god Barbara go get a bug look and
just like really quick and I was like
that would not happen in real life
it would not happen to anybody they
would be we're talking about how someone
emotionally reacts to being like morally
objectified which is the point of book
and that was really fast but the
character Commissioner Gordon I agree
was cool just that was way too quick of
a snack I totally agree with that
yeah right I we're really running out of
time but I wanted to get your guys
thoughts on so the controversy in the
book is that they portray Barbara as
just a victim
and she's a story device in this which
she kind of is that's true what were you
guys thoughts on the original portrayal
of Barbara in this and her losing legs
and everything she's the only female
character in it and she's literally only
used for vice that's I mean that's like
kind of not really arguable that's cool
because now they gave her a really deep
prologue in this where it makes her a
lot more related better yeah right and
if the movie almost made me more mad I
think the problems that like people
could potentially have with Barbara
Gordon and her portrayal in Killing Joke
I think it's a really it's I think it's
super edgy I think it's really cool and
she ends up being like this badass
Oracle so like no type I like how it
turned out for her I mean you can't
really argue anything other than just
saying she's used to crippled like
whenever you they made it so much I mean
it works exactly because they just made
her even more nutless huh and like all
her motivation was coming from like I
just wanted like yeah the user is a
victim but I didn't have a problem with
it because the fact that you know we see
these superheroes and they're there
fighting and all this stuff and they're
dodging bullets and all this and that
but you know and they feel almost
invincible in the rider out of it she's
you know she's a regular human and then
that's just how quick this stuff can
happen in real life doesn't write the
Joker you can just get shot by someone
you don't even know it if the fact she
opens the door and he's got the gun he
sticks it to her stomach and he pulls
the trigger it's that's it she's a
victim and that could happen to anybody
that could happen to Batman and he's
Batman you know but it doesn't know what
it's like
yeah the user is a victim but I think it
works well and it shows how fragile they
are and other superheroes but they're
still human I get the point
I think I think it works well and I
don't think there's any badness to it
because it's like was shown how fragile
we are right yeah she's a woman but
she's still human yeah
I mean maybe it's because I already knew
the Barbara Gordon character before this
but I you know it didn't affect me that
much when I was reading it like oh she's
a woman victim but I knew Batgirl so
well before that this was just like
another chapter I'm for becoming Oracle
so I was right she's a strong so the
fact she's a victim and one time - right
and this was actually departing her
person named Batman Ron this wasn't like
the it was later released as a
standalone write a book but this is part
of the main Batman line so you know that
you can argue that you know she was
built up before this absolutely other
stories we have to wrap this up I'm
sorry I wouldn't talk for another half
hour but we have trapped us up folks
I'll make sure to like our Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comics show
where can we find your social medias
let's hurry Oh
Twitter Facebook same place as always
okay you can find me on Twitter at
Heather Bruce and Instagram at a truce a
truce
alright you can find me on Twitter and
Austin underscore Walter and until next
week for all these lovely folks here let
us know what you thought of the movie
below I'm sure you guys have so let us
know about the discussion let's keep the
discussion going okay I want to make
these guys are awesome we'll see you
next week on next page